على قيد الحياه وسط الانقاذ اوكرانيه
مصدومه بجوار حوض الاستحمام هذا سقطت
الفتاه انستازيا فاست من الطابق الخامس
لهذه البنايه هي قصه مؤلمه للفتاه
الاوكرانيه البالغه من العمر 23 عاما
هنا د نيترو على بعد 130 كيلو مترا من خط
المواجهه كانت انستازيا في المنزل برفقه
والديها قبل ان يطاله قصف صاروخي مفاجئ
ياتيك كنت مستلقيه في غرفتي وفجاه سمعت
انفجار هائلا امتلا المكان بالغبار
والاتربه ارتطمت بالباب وبعدها تمكنت من
التنقل بين الركام وفهمت انه لم تعد هناك
غرف واختفت منازل الجيران ايضا
وبامل النجاه ايضا وبقيت في مكانها مده
ساعه كامله
[موسيقى]
وان يتم اخراجهما من تحت الركام ولكنهما
توفي
تمكن عمال الحمايه المدنيه من اجلائها حيه
من بين الانقاض مع بعض انشراح الطفيفه
مواطن
تابع الانفجار والاجلاء ووثق المشاهد
بالصور
اتمنى ان تغير هذه الصوره مسار الحرب ربما
يشاهدها اصحاب القرار في اوروبا ويفهمون
ما تقوم به روسيا هنا
خسرت انستازيا شفاست والديها وخطيبها خلال
الحرب قصتها هي واحده من قصص ماساويه
كثيره في اوكرانيا